are you still a Patriots fan Tom Brady I
had him on the show he is leaving the
Patriots he's going to Tampa I never
understood you love football he tried to
buy a team what do you got oh there's
your Patriots Patriots that's that fella
checks hoodie wow that's actually
Belichick's sweatshirt he gave you that
yeah first of all do you want me to give
you some of my old clothes you can hang
on a wall anything I got shoes I could
send over that I don't wear anymore I
mean wait a second you're a guy from
Jersey
you're so proudly from New Jersey
certainly the Giants could be your team
I find it a betrayal and I don't like
that you're a Patriots fan I mean what
is what is up with that and explain well
to the people
Belichick and I have been really good
friends for 30 plus years back to the
late 80s so he was just an assistant
nobody back in the in the mid 80s and we
became pals
so wherever he and Parcells went I got
to be the mascot so when they left the
Giants and they went on to Dallas for
Parcells and Cleveland for Belichick I
was the mascot and wherever these guys
went I would go and visit and stayed
pals with everybody so my relationship
with all of those guys just got deeper
as the years went on and so yes and I
became a very deep patriot fan for a lot
a lot of years because my guys were
there Parcells was there Belichick was
there then I became close to mr. Kraft
and I would have fan there so long that
Brady was the backup quarterback when I
was a fan why would Belichick think to
give you his sweatshirt and you would
hang it on a wall it's fascinating it
was a Christmas gift that my wife got
framed and he had beat the Jets and it
was a monumental win in his career and
and so he gave me that as a keepsake
do you ever trade clothes with him
in other words you have some of your
fringe 1980